Instead of just making a one
variable kernel density estimate,
we could use multivariate
density estimates.
Multivariate kernel density estimates
will give us joint probability density
functions from which we can
draw conditional probabilities.
In this case, we can use another
second variable denoted as
x bar which could be the difference
between f0 and f2 divided by f0.
This will then be the difference
of the submitted charge amount and
the Medicare allowed amount,
divided by the submitted charge amount.
Let's take a look at what
the kernel density estimate for
the joint distribution of x and
x bar looks like.
Back to your iPython notebook.
We have defined a new variable called
xbar which is the absolute value
of the difference between f0 and
f2 divided by f0.
We can use a very convenient
joint plot function included in
to make the joint kernel density
estimate of the variables x and x bar.
Let's run this piece of code.
This might take a while to run.
The star here indicates that the
computer is still working on your plot.
Have patience and
you will get a nice looking figure.
Once that code finishes running,
you will get a two-dimensional
plot looking like this.
On each axis we have plotted
the one dimensional PDFs.
The joint distribution is
given as this heat map here.
Looking at the joint PDF,
you can see that there is
a cluster around the point 00.
There is also another one around 0.8.
There could be another
cluster somewhere around 0.6.
You can ask several different
questions after you have a joint KDE.
Notice that the multivariate kernel
density estimation was made behind
the scene, and all you see is
the plot of the probability density.
You can use multivariate
KDEs to do regressions.
You can also use them to do pattern
classification using Bayes' decision
rules.
The usefulness of KDEs is also to
determine the shape of the data
very quickly without having
to collect a lot of data and
can be used for online models and
high velocity data.
In the next lessons,
we're going to look at some ways
to determine if we have
outliers in the data.
We covered a little bit of kernel
density estimates as part of
nonparametric methods in statistics.
However, the subject is really vast.
We recommend the book All of
Nonparametric Statistics by
Larry Wasserman if you want to
learn more about the subject.
A link to the book is given
in the instructors notes.
In the next lesson,
we're going to look at a simple way to
see if there are outliers in our data.